dude i did you a favor you know how you
called me up and you said you loved
beetlejuice yeah i brought them in for
you he's gonna sit next to you beat all
look at that yeah
look at the outfit
you have that shirt yeah
don't kid yourself you should've put
beetlejuice in your movie look at how
slow he walks in what a stud i want to
get a good shot he walks in like apollo
creed walked into rocky
has a lot of confidence anyway so uh
david spade is a big fan of yours this
is david spade
what's up buddy he's a big fan of yours
yeah he is he wanted to meet you
he called me up and he said he wanted to
meet you david you're not that much
taller than beetlejuice no i'm not no
he's cooler though who has a better
build david spade or beetlejuice robin
field just has a better shirt on i was
looking at beetlejuice has broad
shoulders the beetlejuice is in good
shape you work out yeah i'll work out
yeah what do you do what's your routine
a lot of things
these are little hundred and eighty
pounds over you work out with a trainer
yeah our best price 125. 125. sweet put
it up dude all right nice that's more
than howard does you're damn right it is
you bench and what else squats and
squats squad like
5 30. 530 pounds yeah just that sounds a
little high
he could change that number at any time
i like when he interviewed him and he
was on a movie set and you go what's
moving about he goes i don't know
tell me about the movie what's this
movie about i don't know i don't know
you gotta ask them i don't know do you
know you know what your scene's about
your character i don't know i don't got
nothing to do with this do you know your
character's name in the movie i don't
know you gotta ask them i don't know you
gotta ask these guys i don't know
is it really yeah it's already out it's
all ready it's already out i like how
this story's fun
your movie hasn't come out yet it's a
big it's a big movie it takes hours to
do it it takes an hour
nobody could have played this part but
you though right beetle yeah all the
paul i could play
yo just thanks for waking up early and
coming and hanging with me buddy
[Music]
the best